as a chef I'm never sniffy about cooking
with vegetables because I know that with
a bit of care and attention they can be
turned into something absolutely
stunning for my ultimate vegetarian
lunch I've got a couple of fantastic
recipes lightly fried my delicious
halloumi and courgette cakes squeeze
every last bit of flavor out of those
vegetables but first I'm preparing a
simple slow roast tomato and watercress
salad
these chose mutters are perfect if you
haven't got cherry tomatoes vitam are as
good or even just big normal plum
tomatoes lay the tomatoes on the tray
and these go into the oven for about 90
minutes if you turn the oven down really
low you can leave them in overnight so
be honest longer you leave them the
better they taste
once you've season with salt I sprinkle
over with some sugar and the salt and
sugar combined speeds up the drying
process because you want that nice chewy
texture and then you get these little
thyme flowers and just pick off the buds
garlic slice then just spread that on
now the tray looks quite full and
compact but 90 minutes in the oven
you'll see everything spring down all
the skins blistering and the flavor
intensifies so nicely extra virgin olive
oil that gives a nice earthy flavor to
the tomatoes place your tomatoes into an
oven preheated to 150 degrees C and cook
long and slow for an hour and a half now
halloumi cakes there's something quite
exciting about halloumi cheese it's a
very firm cheese and it fries
brilliantly
kill the carrots
grapes not too finely you want that nice
texture next courgette
the secret is keeping all your grated
the same for that into a sieve a
sprinkling of salt will draw out liquid
from the vegetables then grate the
halloumi halloumi cheese doesn't look
that tasty but once you've got color on
it in the pan it's really really
delicious
now really important to squeeze out the
excess water in the veg you'll see all
that water that needs to come out of
there if we didn't do this you'll make
your little patties non fireball because
the whole thing starts to separate and
then mix in with the cheese spring
onions chop up the whites under greens
now we're going to season that with some
delicious fresh mint and fresh coriander
whenever it's vegetarian I like to put a
combination of herbs in there tarragon
and parsley mint to coriander basil and
lemon grass all delicious on their own
but in tandem their flavors play off
each other next two eggs in give that a
little mix add the eggs to the mixture
and then finally a couple of tablespoons
of bed crumbs the Beckhams help dry out
any excess moisture mix all the
ingredients together before you start
shaping these taste the mixture hmm it's
really important to identify the
seasoning now if you wait until you've
cooked them they'll be too late to
adjust the seasoning all them two large
gulfport shaken it's like a little mini
burger
you could spice these up with some chili
in there Kevin got fresh chili chili
flakes and it's something that can be
done up a dane advance
to get your cakes firm and ready for
frying put them into the fridge
uncovered for 25 minutes panel get that
nice and hot boss and wait for that I'll
get the dressing ready slicer red chilli
seeds and all on an angle into shards
then chopped fresh ginger seasoned with
a sprinkle of sugar and salt add some
rice wine vinegar add a couple of
tablespoons of olive oil to finish off
some chopped coriander got a sweet sour
spicy flavor with my chilli dressing
done I can start frying off my halloumi
cakes in a hot oiled pan we get a nice
crisp edge you already start to smell
that sauteed halloumi with the
courgettes and carrots smells delicious
really important for a nice amount of
color on them as my cakes sizzle away I
can finish off my roast tomato salad one
of my favorite knees has to be
watercress just cut off stalks
[Music]
Sherlock rings watercress - Sherlock
yeah brilliantly well together oh Sh lot
look so dainty when you open up these
little ringlets don't forget to turn
your cakes now tomatoes whatever you
don't use just Jardin I put them in the
fridge you just drop those slow-cooked
warm tomatoes over the watercress the
sweetness is incredible absolutely
delicious little drizzle for the Aged
I'll smooth vinegar gives that tartness
to the watercress watercress is
naturally peppery so there's need any
pepper just little touch of salt and
then a light sprinkling of extra-virgin
olive oil
after five minutes on a medium heat my
halloumi cakes are ready so important
I've taken out that water
[Music]
you can see it doesn't disintegrate and
then just get your dressing take a spoon
of it and then tilt it to the side
because with the garnish I don't want
the juice but that does not turn you on
to become a vegetarian for the knives I
honestly don't know what will
delicious
[Music]
my crispy golden halloumi courgette and
herb cakes with a sumptuous roast tomato
more cress salad all of the flavor with
none of the meat
[Music]